Thank you so much.
Thank you so fucking much for bringing up Shakira and her fucking ex,
because. And then. What a fucking fool.
Just. Okay.
Oh, my god.
I could do a whole fucking series on the women.
Like the woman who dated Shakira's ex
and willingly got in the passenger seat.
What was the fucking car joke she makes?
She says in the thing I gotta fucking hold on in her song.
She says, you exchanged a Ferrari for a twinkle,
meaning a really expensive,
nice car for a really shitty,
little stupid fucking car.
And you change your Rolex for Casio.
What I can't understand is the fucking woman
who's willing to ride in that car
fucking with him and be like, yeah,
that's right, we're downgrades, and we love that.
Like, how do you not see that you're just a tool?
How do you not see that
you're just being used as some fucking arm candy
to try to make her jealous?
But what are you really telling us with those fucking actions?
What you're telling us is you fucking bumped that song so hard,
you memorized the lyrics, understood all the references.
You're clearly not over her.
You're so fucking bent about her,
you're making yourself look like a fool just to try to stay relevant,
just to try to get yourself noticed by her somehow. It's like you,
the